merci bonsoir bonjour pardon à toute sa
base et à tous alors que les régions
socialistes
excepté l'alsace cher philippe richert
qui ont augmenté leur dette de deux fois
et demie oui on peut applaudir l'alsace
on peut bravo alors que la fiscalité a
triplé on aurait pu espérer
jean-pierre que cette manne financière
ajustements aux prérogatives de la
région haye sur les lycées haye sur
l'apprentissage haye sur l'économie bien
que constate-t-on entre 2010 et 2014 des
investissements sur les lycées recul de
285 millions d'euros l'investissement
sur l'économie coeur de lance
effectivement de l'action des régions
pour relayer l'économie la dynamiser
permettre aux entreprises de s'installer
ne représentent plus que 8% du budget
l'apprentissage effectivement qui est
également au coeur de métier de la
région non seulement recul mais les
crédits d'apprentissage ne sont même pas
utilisés à leur hauteur pour permettre à
nos jeunes et à nos moins jeunes
l'apprentissage chasse jusqu'à 30 ans
est bien de trouver un emploi
l'agriculture n'est pas protégé
tous ces éléments montrent très bien que
même dans leur coeur de métier dans
leurs cordes de compétences les régions
socialistes ont failli bien ce n'est pas
une fatalité
mesdames et messieurs puisqu'on voit
également qu'il y à une région elle qui
a réussi et cette région c'est l'alsace
la seule région qui étaient restés à
droite et elle a réussi et ce sont les
alsaciens qui le disent le mieux dans un
sondage qui est parue récemment dans la
presse quotidienne nationale que disait
l'ensemble des habitants sur leur région
ils ne la connaissais pas il ne la
voyait pas il trouvait qu'elle n'avait
pas réussi des sondages qui allait en
général sur des taux de réussite des
présidents socialistes entre 35 et 36 %
et bien la région alsace avec une
présidence de droite et du centre avec
philippe richert elle atteignait 54 %
donc on voit bien que la seule région
qui était reconnue active positive
travaillant pour l'intérêt de ses
concitoyens c'était une région qui était
gérée par la droite et le centre
c'est ce que vous nous nous vous
proposons pour demain il faut tous
ensemble que nous unissions nous
énergie pour fait de cette élection
régionale une élection gagnante
merci